schule wären krone also ich blicke dann
nicht mehr durch in berlin war es so
dass die schon zu erschließen sollten
dann sollten sie offen sein und am ende
waren sie doch zu und ärgert wir euch
auch über lehrer die am montagfrüh panel
die aufgaben für ihre schüler abwerfen
und dann für den rest der woche nicht
mehr erreichbar sind
ich bin thomas reichert ich bin
korrespondent im zdf hauptstadtstudio
und ich habe zwei schulpflichtige söhne
ich gehöre also zu den millionen eltern
die in dieser pandemie zwei sachen unter
einen hut kriegen müssen die überhaupt
nicht darunter passen homeschooling und
home office und ich frage mich warum die
schulen in den bislang zehn monaten der
pandemie so wenig dazugelernt hatten
zehn monate ist doch eigentlich ein
ganzes schuljahr zeit für zeugnisse also
[Musik]
widrigen heute mal den spieß um stehen
die schulen ein crooner zeugnis aus und
vergeben noten und am ende zeige ich
euch die vier gravierendsten folgen die
sich daraus für unsere kinder und für
uns alle ergeben ist es zeit für einen
blauen brief an unsere schulen weil sie
extrem versetzungsgefährdet sind
erinnert ihr euch noch kaum gegen mitte
dezember der shutter und los crash in
ganz deutschland die schulserver hier
ich hab's mir ausgesucht in mecklenburg
vorpommern gegen am ersten tag die schul
plattform ist lernen geliebten in
sachsen anhalt waren mittel nicht
erreichbar
ähnlich wie sachsen und rheinland pfalz
in berlin erweist sich der lernraum als
fiasko
nach den weihnachtsferien drei stunden
lang nicht erreichbar oder kurse waren
verschwunden
den vogel schießt bayern ab das land von
laptop und lederhose
die lernplattform dort heißt babys von
ist so unzuverlässig dass der
kultusminister sogar davor warnt sich zu
nutzen
sein rat an lehrer und schüler nehmt
lieber das telefon
kein witz die probleme sind eigentlich
seit langem bekannt aber warum ist dann
in den letzten monaten nichts besser
geworden warum klappt das immer noch
nicht
irgendjemand muss er dafür
verantwortlich sein die schulen in
deutschland koordiniert die
kultusministerkonferenz und deren chefin
habe ich mal gefragt wenn alle
schülerinnen und schüler in einem
bundesland gleichzeitig mit
videofunktion auf die plattform
zugreifen
dann wird es eng wenn es schon eng wird
wenn alle schüler die darauf zugreifen
sondern zu greifen dann zeigt es ja wie
schlecht wir eigentlich ausgerüstet sind
oder es zeigt dass deutschland zu spät
begonnen hat aber das wissen wir deshalb
ist der digital pakt zwischen bund
ländern ja auch vereinbart worden
nächste frage was schätzt ihr wie viele
achtklässler haben in deutschland an
ihren schulen zugang zu wählen
26 prozent das ist das ergebnis einer
studie von 2009 10 die international
verglichen hat wie weit die schulen bei
der digitalisierung sind 26 prozent das
ist ein weiter weg von dort bis nach
dänemark die haben nämlich wifi wlan an
den schulen 100 prozent an allen schulen
gibt es wlan super oder
die experten von der deutschen
leopoldina haben sich denn immer genauer
angeguckt und schreiben übrigens dazu
der schulbetrieb dort sei trotz lockdown
in der pandemie weitgehend ungestört
fortgesetzt worden weitgehend ungestört
davon können wir hier nur träumen also
die note für digitale ausstattung eine 5
mangelhaft aber okay es geht hier nicht
nur um ausstattung sondern um
lerninhalte vielleicht klappt das ja
besser unterricht ist natürlich nicht
allein deshalb toll weil der digital
stattfindet aber im moment ist es doch
so entweder unterricht ist digital oder
es gibt überhaupt keine und deshalb muss
ich hier mal kurz aus nur so ein
familien nähkästchen plaudern ihr wisst
ihr schon dass ich zwei söhne habe
sie gehen auf zwei verschiedenen schulen
beim älteren ist es so dass sie gerade
jetzt erst mit regelmäßigen
videokonferenzen anfangen
ansonsten haben sehen ziemlich
alleingelassen beim jüngeren ist es
genau das gegenteil der klappt es super
seit dem ersten tag haben die
lernplattformen lehrer schüler chats
videokonferenzen alles digital
meine familie und ich leben deshalb in
dieser pandemie in zwei völlig
unterschiedlichen welten in der einen
stau nicht darüber was mein jüngerer
sohn digital alles lernen kann und in
der anderen verzweifle ich über die
langsamkeit unseres systems und darüber
welches potenzial die in dieser zeit
wegwerfen natürlich kann das alles daran
liegen dass mein jüngster sohn auf eine
privatschule geht und mein älterer auf
eine staatliche schule stimmt schon
jetzt würde ich sagen privatschulen die
haben ja auch das geld aber ich glaube
das trifft es nicht ganz die lern
software die diese schule nutzt die es
kostenlos
der grund ist glaube ich eher ein
anderer hat nichts mit privat oder
staatlich zu tun
viele schulen haben digitales lernen
schlicht verpennt corona bringt es jetzt
das licht und den preis dafür den
bezahlen unsere kinder
bildungsexperten sind darüber echt
verzweifelt wenn wir über lehren und
lehrerfortbildung im digitalen bereich
sprechen dann sind viele lehren und
lehrer fortbilden
den beibringen wie man laptop an stellt
aber wie man den und gerät
gewinnbringend im unterricht wirklich
einsetzen kann bzw auch damit ein mehr
wirtschaft gegenüber dem normalen buch
da besteht eigentlich kaum expertise bei
denjenigen die in deutschland die lehre
mit lehrer ausbilden ist ein riesen bank
also welche note für digitales lernen
tut mir leid schule auch da nur ein
mangelhaft aber streng sich denn jetzt
alle richtig an um von diesen schlechten
noten runter zu kommen um es besser zu
machen
extra für die schulen gibt es seit 2009
10 einen digital pakt bund und länder
haben 55 5 milliarden euro in einen topf
gepackt während der panne kam dann noch
mal 500 millionen euro nur für ipads und
laptops dazu und was ist mit dem geld
passiert meine kollegen vom redaktions
netzwerk deutschland haben wir
nachgefragt und die antwort ist
ernüchternd gerade mal 17 prozent der
mittel sind bisher genehmigt worden
angekommen dass fast nichts ich verstehe
das nicht
und da stehen also milliarden für
digitale bildung bereit und sie werden
einfach nicht genutzt
wie kann das sein wir haben eine riesen
liste von problemen die eigentlich
glaube ich jeder in deutschland
mittlerweile herunter rattern kann aber
es fehlt zu dieser mut eben nicht nur an
nächste woche zu denken sondern
tatsächlich mal anzupacken zu sagen wir
schauen jetzt wie geht das die nächsten
monate weiter und wie können wir das
auch grundsätzlich klären also
zwischenzeugnis deutschland schulen
schneiden nicht nur schlecht ab beim
digitalen lernen auch die chance es
besser zu machen
mit den milliarden aus dem digital packt
die lässt man einfach sausen und jetzt
nochmal wer ist dafür eigentlich
verantwortlich
bildung ist ländersache das heißt für
die schulen sind 16 verschiedene
kultusminister verantwortlich und damit
da nicht jeder jetzt sein ganz eigenes
süppchen kocht gibt es eine
kultusministerkonferenz die kmk was die
macht auf ihrer website schreiben sie
sie wollen in angelegenheiten von
länderübergreifender bedeutung für das
notwendige maß an gemeinsamkeit in
bildung wissenschaft und kultur sorgen
helmut kohl sogar der straße sie sei die
reaktion erste einrichtung in der
bundesrepublik hat schröder sagte nach
dem pisa schock
wir müssen die schulen verteidigen und
nicht die kultusminister heute ist das
nicht viel anders ich habe mit vielen
über die kmk gesprochen
das eine kann ich euch sagen ihr ruf ist
seit diesen zeiten nicht viel besser
geworden die kmk ist der große pandemie
versage das was die kmk immer verspricht
dieses großem maß an gemeinsamkeit das
kriegt sie einfach nicht hin in dieser
pandemie
es kann nicht sein dass montags dekra
entscheidet es gibt ein stufenplan zur
eröffnung am dienstag die mpk es wird
nicht eine schließung und damit höhere
steuern und einzelhändler sie öffnen
vielleicht die residenz wird das ist
genau das was man nicht braucht das ist
nicht so sehr ein problem der kmk der
ruf ruiniert wird oder nicht sondern es
ist ein problem der verbindlichkeit von
solchen regeln das einzige verbindliche
was man von ihr hört ist dass sich die
schulen offen halten will um jeden preis
das finde ich eigentlich gut
homeschooling ist kein ersatz für die
richtige schule aber ich werde den
verdacht nicht los dass die kmk deshalb
so auf offene schulen drängt weil sie
beim digitalen lernen so versagt hat und
das einfach nicht in den griff kriegt
dabei hat sie beim präsenzunterricht
noch eine andere großbaustelle die
ziemlich gefährlich ist
eigentlich hätten die 16
kultusministerin und minister im sommer
genug zeit gehabt und sich zu überlegen
wie man den herbst und winter unterricht
gestaltet ohne gefahr zu laufen dass
sich viele mit krone einstecken aber die
kmk und erstmal ferien nach nun hat den
sommer schlicht patent erst nach dem 10
hat sie das umweltbundesamt zum beispiel
gefragt wie man klassenzimmer richtig
lüftet na im ernst und die antwort vom
umweltbundesamt die kann dann auch als
wochen später ist die schulen schon
wieder in vollem betrieb waren hier
da gab es eine vierseitige handreichung
zum richtigen lüften da geht es unter
anderem stoßlüften und wer lüften und
wenn es im winter richtigkeit wird was
macht man dann
man muss sich vielleicht wirklich ein
bisschen etwas wärmeres noch zum
anziehen mitbringen vielleicht macht man
auch mal eine kleine kniebeuge oder so
oder klatscht in die hände damit man ein
bisschen warm wird kann man machen oder
man nutzt zum beispiel luftfilter
studien von wissenschaftlern der
bundeswehr uni und der frankfurter uni
zeigen die sind extrem effektiv wehren
aus der luft herauszufiltern
aber die meisten kultusminister sind
trotzdem dagegen ist ihnen offenbar zu
teuer
wobei selbst billigere lösungen
die werden noch nicht mal richtig
erwogen das ist die besucher mit der wir
gibt das notwendige er jetzt tun und was
wir dann noch an kleinen waffen brauchen
das gucken wir später gut da gibt es
also viele milliarden für die wirtschaft
aber wo ist eigentlich die perser für
die bildung wie es weit und breit nichts
zu sehen
nicht jetzt in der pandemie wo das
menschenrecht auf bildung seit monaten
nicht gewährleistet wird deutschland die
bildungsrepublik gibt im vergleich zu
anderen industrieländern viel zu wenig
für bildung aus und das institut für
urbanistik hat ausgerechnet dass es
einen riesigen investitionsstau an es
fehlen über 40 milliarden euro
bei uns im reichen deutschland so und
jetzt ist es zeit für ein zeugnis für
die kmk die kultusministerkonferenz
kommt machen wir den alten lehrer trick
wie würden sie sich denn selbst
einschätzen frau ernst das ist nicht
meine aufgabe in noten an die
kultusministerkonferenz zu geben wir
stellen uns gerne der öffentlichen
kritik
und da gibt es auch viele und da freuen
uns auf den dialog verstehen dann mach
ich das halt der fünf mangelhaft unser
bildungssystem ist also akut
versetzungsgefährdet aber schuld daran
sind nicht allein die 16 kultusminister
und ministerin
das problem liegt schon auch beim bund
die bildungsministerin anja karliczek
hat es bis heute nicht geschafft dafür
zu sorgen dass es weniger bürokratie und
eine schnellere auszahlung der
milliarden des digital paktes gibt und
weil wir die ganze zeit über
digitalisierung sprechen was hat
eigentlich dorothea die staatsministerin
für digitalisierung in der pandemie für
die schulen getan schreibt es mir gerne
vielleicht habe ich was übersehen
ich musste jetzt schon 35 vergeben und
ich habe euch die vier gravierendsten
folgen aus all diesen fehlern und
versäumnissen für unsere kinder und für
uns alle versprochen und hier sind sie
erstens all jene die sich sowieso schon
schwer tun in der schule werden noch
weiter abgehängt weil sie sich mit dem
lernen schwer tun weil sie aus
bildungsfernen familien kommen und vor
allem weil es jetzt kaum mehr jemanden
gibt der sich wirklich um sie kümmert
zweitens das versagen beim
gesundheitsschutz in den schulen wird
zur gefahr für schüler und lehrer und am
ende für die ganze gesellschaft dritter
im pisa ranking droht deutschland noch
viel weiter abzurutschen als das eh
schon passiert ist und viertens wie
verspielen mit all dem die
zukunftschancen unserer kinder und des
landes insgesamt aber sag mir was denkt
jeder darüber welche noten würdet ihr
unserem schulsystem vergeben und was
glaubt ihr was müsste passieren damit
das menschenrecht auf bildung in dieser
pandemie nicht ganz hinten runterfällt
und wenn es euch gefallen hat mach dein
like darunter und folgt uns weiter wir
freuen uns wenn auch das nächste mal der
insight politics mit dabei sein und mit
uns hinter die kulissen der
die tig schaut